madame la ministre ça va elle a écrit
secrétaire d'État chargée de la
biodiversité je le disais c'est une
journée malheureusement importante à
partir d'aujourd'hui on vit à crédit on
a dépassé toutes les ressources que peut
nous donner la planète on en parle
chaque année c'est quand même important
alors cette année ça arrive 5 jours plus
tard mais c'est en changement de calcul
faut pas y voir un résultat encourageant
c'est une journée qui est assez grave en
réalité et en même temps il faut la
comprendre parce qu'on dit le jour du
dépassement c'est le jour où on a
consommé en une année plus que ce que la
planète naturellement peut reproduire
pour reconstruire et donc on vit à
crédit on vit à crédit ça veut dire que
en fait on épuise des ressources alors
des on les on les on les épuise
tellement que en fait on épuise la
planète de ce fait et face à ça on a
plusieurs enjeux comme on a absolument
en conscience de cette gravité et que
cette situation ne peut pas durer alors
on a mis en place un certain nombre de
mesures de projets et le président de la
République a fait de la planification
écologique la priorité du quinquennat en
mobilisant d'abord la première ministre
puisque c'est exactement et c'est toute
la force de l'équipe gouvernementale et
ensuite évidemment le déploiement de ma
feuille de route en particulier mais je
profite de ce moment pour dire que dans
le fond quand on parle de biodiversité
parfois tout le monde n'y met pas la
même chose derrière la biodiversité
c'est quoi dans le fond c'est la nature
nous avons besoin de la nature et la
nature a besoin de du changement de
notre comportement au quotidien parce
que la nature c'est évidemment ce qui
nous nourrit mais c'est ce qui nous
soigne c'est ce qui nous protège et nous
vivons ensemble et pour arrêter cette
effondrement du vivant et bien plus que
jamais nous avons besoin d'être
ambitieux et c'est exactement ce que
porte entre autres la stratégie
nationale biodiversité 2030 c'est ce que
porte le gouvernement dans un certain
nombre d'actions et je suis très
heureuse de le faire sous évidemment
l'autorité de Christophe BECHU qui est
le Ministre en charge à la transition
écologique et la cohésion des
territoires parce que il n'y a pas de
transformation de transition qui se
fasse sans la faire au plus près des
territoires et c'est là où on a besoin
des élus locaux tout à l'heure vous en
parliez nous avons besoin des
associations dont nous a des citoyens
et on a aussi besoin des entreprises qui
pourraient aller un peu plus vite et
certainement un peu plus loin mais on
sera à leur côté pour le faire et
justement je dis aujourd'hui c'est un
peu une moyenne parce que nous en France
on a épuisé nos réserves depuis le 5 mai
ça veut dire qu'on est mauvais élève on
les a épuisés plus vite mais on est
aussi le pays en Europe et dans le monde
qui s'engage le plus fortement je
donnais juste quelques exemples
typiquement on est en train de
travailler sur un Écosse c'est-à-dire
permettre à chaque citoyen de savoir
quel est l'impact environnemental sur la
biodiversité sur le climat d'un produit
qu'on pourrait acheter dans son épicerie
dans son supermarché ou même sur plus
largement en France on réduit et de
manière très forte ou on régule les
importations d'ailleurs on va jusqu'à
interdire un certain nombre
d'importations de produits qui viennent
de la déforestation c'est hyper
important on donne aussi les moyens nos
citoyens parce que quand tu es français
tu tiens à tes paysages tu tiens à ta
nature et c'est vrai c'est quelque chose
qui nous appartient au village bien sûr
on est tous habitué mais c'est quelque
chose de très fort et donc on donne les
moyens et bien grâce à la météo des
forêts faire extrêmement attention au
forêt qui nous entoure parce que 90% des
cas c'est malheureusement l'action
humaine c'est un mégot qui est malette
et qui finalement va mettre un créer un
drame c'est à dire un incendie dans une
forêt les derniers quelques heures en
quelques heures et il faut 100 ans pour
une forêt pour que ça pousse météo des
forêts qu'on peut retrouver sur le site
de Météo France mais aussi l'eau la
question de l'eau aujourd'hui vous avez
il y a plus d'une centaine de communes
où il a une régulation de l'eau courante
plus largement sur d'autres territoires
la question de l'eau pareil chaque
citoyen peut aller regarder c'est un
outil assez simple qui s'appelle vigieo
qui a été mis en place par le
gouvernement pour permettre à chacun de
savoir s'il peut arroser ce qu'il ne
peut pas arroser on accompagne les élus
à faire à utiliser de l'eau qui a été
traité pour moins consommer mais aussi
on va chercher des entreprises en disant
maintenant il faut aller sur de la
sobriété parce qu'on sait que c'est pas
forcément celles qui jouent le plus le
jeu entre les citoyens et les élus
locaux dont vous avez parlé moi je moi
je crois et c'est le projet qui est
celui de notre majorité on croit
collectivement à une écologie des
solutions c'est à dire que chacun peut
prendre sa part mais on sait aussi qu'il
faut être extrêmement ambitieux compte
tenu de la réalité de la situation de la
planète si on venait à ne pas faire de
changement je n'ai juste un petit
exemple et qu'on ne tient pas là-bas des
1 degrés 5 et bien on verrait en
quelques
en quelques même pas décennies on
verrait un effondrement des coraux 90%
la quasi totalité des coraux marins
disparaîtrait ce qui veut dire au-delà
de la beauté des coraux et de la
nécessité des coraux dans notre
biodiversité un quart des animaux qui
sont dans la mer et des écosystèmes
exactement et c'est là où l'humain c'est
là où on oppose pas l'humain et la
nature en fait nous à être humain sur
notre sur notre planète nous avons
besoin de cette nature et inversement
donc plus on la protège plus on donne
les moyens éducatifs mais aussi de
transformation notre industrie parfois
on est très dur parce qu'on va chercher
cette sobriété par des interdictions je
pense aussi à nos positions européennes
qui sont extrêmement fortes et bien plus
on accompagne ce changement mais moi je
suis convaincu et c'est la stratégie que
nous avons posé d'abord votre objectif
c'est d'arrêter l'effondrement du vivant
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est à vue d'oeil
c'est à vue d'oeil on voit des espèces
disparaitre on voit la question par
exemple des abeilles qui qui pareil
aujourd'hui on sait à quel point les
pollinisateurs sont essentiels si demain
il n'y avait plus d'abeilles alors on
aurait plus de fruits on aurait plus on
aurait pu l'aiguës de cette réaction en
chaîne je pense que des exemples que
vous venez citez de se dire on se rend
compte aussi de toute l'influence du
vivant de cet écosystème en fait qui vit
par lui-même c'est notre c'est notre
c'est notre vie de tous les jours et
c'est là où moi je ne veux pas laisser
imaginer que la biodiversité c'est en
opposition ou en contradiction avec
notre vie quotidienne bien au contraire
par contre ce qui est certain c'est que
la biodiversité elle vit la pression de
cinq grandes familles et si vous me
permettez peut-être ces cinq grandes
familles parce que on est dans une
journée un peu particulière la première
c'est la déforestation et de l'autre
côté l'artification des sols donc c'est
quand même une action humaine pour le
coup la deuxième c'est la
surexploitation de de parfois de nos
mères de nos de notre faune et d'autres
fleurs exploite la nature qui est autour
de nous la troisième qui est assez forte
c'est le changement climatique et c'est
là on le vit en fait on voit le
réchauffement de la planète on a vu
l'été qu'on a vécu l'année dernière on
voit les inondations
en fait on a des tempêtes on a des gros
incendies on a des canicules on a de la
sécheresse et puis c'est pas parti pour
s'améliorer si on n'est pas dans une
action forte de l'autre côté on a des
pollutions je pense à nos pour le coup à
nos
ultras aux ultramarins à la Guyane avec
leur paillage illégale ou finalement on
détruit la planète pour aller chercher
de l'or ça c'est vraiment de la
pollution directe alors elles sont
diverses et la dernière c'est alors pour
le coup la place que peut prendre les
espèces exocytes envahissantes là pour
le coup c'est aussi un sujet de l'été
mais on connaît tous les moustiques
tigres et oui mais les moustiques tigres
c'est une réalité les frelons asiatiques
on en parle aussi beaucoup parce que ça
vient voilà dans dans nos villes dans
nos espaces de villégiature et sauf que
les frelons asiatiques qui tuent en fait
nos abeilles et c'est là où attention
c'est 5 éléments de pression c'est les
causes aussi pour laquelle de diversité
et ben elle s'affaisse et nous notre
réponse elle est assez simple on stoppe
puis on inverse en appuyant cause après
cause et on a une stratégie nationale
pour le faire un budget historique mais
évidemment la stratégie biodiversité de
mi-30 qui reprend j'imagine un peu les
points que vous ne citer ça en fait la
stratégie nationale de dureté vous avez
raison 2030 elle s'appuie sur ses 5
causes qui mettent de la pression sur
l'effondrement du vivant et donc sur
qu'est-ce qui effondre aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui fait que des vivants qui
disparaissent de notre planète il y a 5
causes donc on va lutter contre les cinq
causes d'abord on veut les arrêter et
ensuite inverser et pour ça il faut
réparer je donne un exemple très simple
pour réparer qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
on peut replanter un milliard d'arbre
c'est le projet du président mais parce
que une forêt il faut 100 ans bien sûr
et aujourd'hui on voit quelque chose
d'assez franchement je l'ai vu en forêt
de Sologne il y a quelques quelques
jours avec Marc fenault qui a mis de
l'agriculture on voit des arbres mourir
d'une mort brutale et ça s'appelle comme
ça c'est une mort brutale de l'arbre
parce que l'arbre il a pas eu le temps
avec ce changement climatique ce
réchauffement et bien de s'adapter cette
nouvelle température et donc d'un coup
il s'effondre et bien face à ça nous
avons besoin et bien d'accompagner nos
forêts nos forêts ont et les Français
tiennent à leur forêt c'est un
patrimoine on a grandi avec donc
accompagner cette cette effondrement
qu'on vise et accompagner les essences
c'est-à-dire les la nature de ces arbres
il faut les protéger et du coup j'en
profite parce que c'est là où les hommes
et les femmes qui nous protègent aussi
sont essentielles et ça peut pompier qui
sont extrêmement mobilisés cet été je
voudrais pour terminer de parler de
dépassement je sais pas si vous avez vu
aymeric Caron qui vous interpelle sur
Twitter je me permets de vous faire voir
ce twitch il dit le jour du dépassement
qui tombe au milieu de l'année il vous
interpelle directement c'est à cause du
modèle productiviste que vous promouvez
celui qui ne jure que par la
consommation et le PIB c'est en raison
de l'agriculture intensive que vous
défendez en raison de ses grands patrons
que vous chouchoutez bref votre message
rempli d'éléments de langage qui brasse
du vent c'est l'hôpital qui se trouve la
charité je voulais vous donner
l'occasion quand même puisqu'il vous
interpelle directement et vous êtes sur
plateau de lui répondre et de défendre
c'est une très jolie occasion parce
qu'il se trouve que c'est exactement les
comportements de personnes comme les
propos d'Aymeric Caron qui font que en
fait il oppose il oppose les gens il
oppose les entreprises aux citoyens ils
l'opposent le citoyen allait local il
l'opposent le français finalement à sa
planète c'est exactement ce qu'il ne
faut pas faire c'est très simple
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus le choix en
fait pour pour le bien-être de nos
enfants mais bien sûr et puis on n'est
pas obligé d'être dans une radicalité
aussi violente que ces propos là ce que
je vois c'est des entreprises qui ont
envie pour un grand nombre d'entre elles
de participer à leur transformation
parce qu'il y a des Français qui
prennent conscience en très grande
majorité que s'il y a plus cette nature
et ben c'est la terre de nos enfants on
va faire très souvent besoin d'être
accompagné quand même mais oui ils ont
pas forcément les bons bien sûr on peut
les accompagner il y a parfois où il
faut être un peu plus dur donc il y a
des interdictions qui arrivent c'est
vrai parce qu'il faut mettre extrêmement
ambitieux aussi mais c'est pas en
opposant et c'est pas la méthode qu'on
nous que nous souhaitons moi le projet
qui est le mien et parce que c'est la
demande et de la première ministre et du
président de la République c'est de
mettre autour de la table les gens de
bonne volonté pourquoi jusque maintenant
on arrive à avancer sur plein de sujets
parce que on n'a pas envie d'en faire un
régime politique pour eux c'est un fonds
de commerce et donc ils oppose il divise
il fracture la question réelle qui se
pose c'est quel pays nous voulons quelle
planète nous voulons parce qu'on fait et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait et pour le faire et
bien beaucoup de paroles beaucoup
d'échanges beaucoup de construction des
actes parce qu'aujourd'hui on est à
l'heure des actes et pour ça
concrètement qu'est-ce qu'on met en
place deux milliards sur le fond vert
tous les élus locaux qui aujourd'hui
font et bien de la réutilisation des
eaux usées j'étais à Pornic il y a
quelques jours où on a vu finalement un
maire pouvoir il a transformé un parking
en parc botanique dans le centre ville
de Pornic en Loire-Atlantique et ben il
a continué à pouvoir l'arroser parce que
il utilise de l'eau qui a été réutilisée
et finalement c'est exactement les
exemples tout simple et très concrets du
quotidien on a un litre sur 5 qui est
perdu à cause des fuites dans les
canalisations on accompagne les élus
locaux et finalement ce fond vert c'est
exactement pour ça mais on a aussi
besoin de ramener de la nature dans nos
écoles pour les enfants avec la
renaturation pourquoi parce que ça leur
fait du bien déjà parce que ça c'est
important pour nos enfants de grandir
avec cette nature mais c'est aussi pour
lutter contre les canicules on a vu des
canicules alors si dans notre
centre-ville il n'y a plus d'arbres il
n'y a plus de dilos de fraîcheur
exactement et c'est là où on peut jouer
aux grandes phrases qui bouscule et qui
donne des leçons on peut faire le choix
et bien d'avancer main dans la main avec
tous ceux qui sont de bonne volonté qui
ont envie de protéger d'abord notre nos
paysages la beauté de notre vie notre
planète protéger les espèces qui sont
aujourd'hui en danger mais surtout
surtout construire il y a ceux qui
veulent détruire et à se veulent qui
veulent construire et moi je fais partie
résolument du camp de ceux qui sont
fondamentalement ambitieux pour la
planète ambitieux pour le vivant mais
ambitieux parce que j'ai foi l'homme et
je sais que l'homme paraissant
aujourd'hui vu la conscience que nous
avons de conséquences du dérèglement
climatique et bien nous avons besoin de
cette nature alors on peut la protéger
ensemble et là chacun à sa part et
justement parce que il y a aussi une
partie de communication on a beaucoup
parlé de sobriété énergétiques un peu
l'impression qu'on devait se priver de
tout est-ce qu'il est temps aussi de
faire comprendre aux Français que faire
attention à la planète c'est pas
forcément se priver de tout et cette
écologie punitive qui fait que parfois
les Français ne font pas d'efforts ils
ont l'impression qu'on leur demande
beaucoup trop mais je comprends l'idée
même d'aller imaginer que l'écologie
doit être punitive c'est la meilleure
manière excusez-moi de l'expression mais
de dégoûter tout le monde c'est pas vrai
l'écologie c'est une transformation et
là où il faut être il faut être très
juste il faut expliquer en quoi ça nous
touche tous les jours si on n'avait pas
la planète on aurait pas nos médicaments
nos plantes à manger on aurait pas tout
cela et c'est là où tous ceux qui
essayent d'opposer les agriculteurs les
finalement les amoureux de la nature les
scientifiques ils sont ils sont juste à
contre mon courant il n'apporte aucune
réponse mais l'écologie c'est quoi c'est
comment on fait pour baisser 10% de
consommation d'eau puisque c'est dans le
aujourd'hui dans nos priorités de tous
les secteurs industriels qui consomment
énormément beaucoup d'eau c'est comme on
fait aussi pour s'appuyer et là j'ai cet
esprit j'ai cette exemples en tête
étudiant la biodiversité et donc on se
dit cette réponse elle doit un moment
aller chercher du collectif parce que
tout est grande phrase est-ce qu'elle
transforme bah bien sûr que non alors
oui ça peut créer du débat une polémique
c'est vrai peut-être même aller en top
tweet mais alors au bout de l'histoire
ça n'apporte pas plus d'eau dans la
pratique ça ne répare pas en réalité nos
forêts ça ne prépare pas nos écosystèmes
aux transformations alors pour d'abord
stopper on lutte contre les 5 pressions
et ensuite on inverse parce que c'est ce
qu'on a de plus précieux et en fait
notre destin sont liés et c'est là où il
faut sortir de cette logique extrêmement
punitive et éduquer nos enfants il se
trouve que dimanche était dans un parc
animalier avec avec ma collègue Laurence
avec ma collègue berger et c'était assez
mouvant parce que c'était une
éco-colonie et donc si chacun a tous les
moments de la vie exactement ça devient
plus naturel et donc on accompagne en
réalité ce vivant tout au long de notre
vie sans y voir un lieu de confrontation
pas du tout au contraire pour aller vers
l'ambition il faut faire du collectif un
autre sujet qui demande d'ailleurs vous
amènera à Marseille dans les calanques
c'est la prévention du risque incendie
l'an dernier les pompiers avaient dit
dans une tribune au JDD que la
prévention c'est un angle extrêmement
important pour éviter les images qu'on a
vu qu'on rappelle que malheureusement 9
départs de feu sur 10 sont d'origine
humaine alors parfois involontaire il
est encore temps de rappeler les bons
gestes on en est encore là oui c'est pas
acquis non malheureusement ça ne l'est
pas et pour le coup faut rappeler que
c'est quand même un délit que ça peut
aller sur des peines de prison que les
que les condamnations sont lourdes le on
se rend peut-être pas suffisamment
compte mais je disais tout à l'heure en
quelques heures on perd des hectares de
forêt des pompiers qui risquent leur vie
c'est des soldats du feu mais parfois
ils risquent leur vie et parfois il la
laisse et en mégot ou un barbecue
exactement et donc on a interdit vous
savez le fait de fumer dans les dans les
forêts et à 200 mètres des forêts dans
les espaces où il y a un risque incendie
et donc là il y a un acte citoyen et
franchement pour le coup je viens je
j'ai été il quelques jours en charge de
la jeunesse et de l'engagement et
profondément dans le coeur des Français
il y a ce goût citoyenneté je les invite
à découvrir ces nouvelles outils cet
outil c'est la météo des forêts et quand
on voit qu'autour de soi il y a un
risque alors on fait double extension
bien sûr pour d'abord se mégot bien sûr
mais pas que on a aussi des nouvelles
obligations tout à l'heure je disais
parfois il faut aller chercher des
outils législatives pour réglementaires
la question du débroussaillement
aujourd'hui il est obligatoire autour de
nos forêts et jusqu'à des bandes
entières à plus de 200 mètres autour de
nos forêts parce que ça protège c'est
vous savez c'est c'est des puits de
évidemment c'est 80% de notre
biodiversité mais c'est des plus
forestiers ça capte le CO2 ça nous
permet de nous balader en famille ça
nous permet aussi de partager des
moments qui sont essentiels et ça
protège
c'est c'est des écosystèmes où tout se
tient une forêt c'est un lieu on a des
souvenirs et c'est aussi un lieu qui où
il y a des espèces parfois des espèces
en danger des lieux où on a besoin
finalement de ces arbres pour même notre
construction la construction de nos
villes de nos maisons de nos bâtiments
publics et dans le fond si on a
conscience du fait qu'on est tous liés
alors on fait attention donc un seul
geste d'abord on se renseigne on fait
super attention c'est au risque de la
vie
des soldats du feu et pour le coup c'est
c'est dangereux et là ça appelle
vraiment aussi vite et c'est un délit
donc faut y réfléchir quand même et un
autre sujet qui concerne les calanques
mais pas que et on entend beaucoup
parler cet été c'est celui du sur
tourisme avec des endroits comme les
calanques ou des villages très
touristiques qui sont obligés de mettre
en place par exemple des quotas de
touristes il était temps maintenant
c'est nécessaire d'en passer par là de
se dire si on veut garder ce trésor que
sont ces endroits toujours très beaux
qui sont très jolis sur les réseaux
sociaux mais on les a justement comme
l'émission épuisées et aujourd'hui il
faut faire attention à ces endroits là
on les a vous savez 80% 80% du tourisme
c'est sur 20% de notre de nos
territoires ça vous donne juste un peu
l'idée de la concentration et on a la
chance d'avoir un des plus beaux pays au
monde moi je trouve que notre pays est
magnifique il est beau par ces paysages
par sa nature par son patrimoine
culturel mais aussi patrimoine naturelle
et donc quand on a très envie de voir
les calanques parce que c'est super bon
bah si on a envie que nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants les voient bah faut
peut-être les protéger ça reste aussi
joli et oui on a vu l'état de certains
paysages aujourd'hui ben oui ça se
dégrade mais à vue d'oeil et a vu à vie
de vie humaine et donc pour ça on a
interdit par exemple débarquement sur
certaines plages c'est le premier point
nous on a aussi fait quelque chose de
hyper important que l'information et
donc aujourd'hui il y a même si le mot
est parfois voilà mal interprété une
sorte de quota dire que on peut demander
on peut s'inscrire pour venir mais c'est
ce qui permet de garantir qu'on puisse y
accéder dans de bonnes conditions mais
c'est dans de bonnes conditions et donc
dans le fond c'est gagnant-gagnant c'est
gagnant pour le français qui part en
famille et qui vient peut-être de loin
parce qu'il y a très envie de voir ce
magnifique joyau de notre patrimoine et
c'est un par le voit bien mais
exactement et en même temps on le
protège pour que peut-être les petits
enfants de cette même personne puisse
demain revenir et voir la beauté de ces
paysages et c'est là où c'est une
responsabilité que nous avons dans le
fond chacun met en terme d'héritage la
protection de ces espaces c'est pas pour
enquiquiner les Français c'est pas pour
leur dire non mais si vous avez pas le
flashcode vous rentrez pas c'est pas
pour embêter bien au contraire c'est
pour garantir la préservation et
garantir une transmission et je sais à
quel point on a envie de oui de donner
de donner donner à
aux générations à venir et bien un pays
une planète en bonne santé parce que
dans le fond ça dépend des actes qu'on a
aujourd'hui et qu'on mène aujourd'hui
moi je ne suis pas des défaitistes mais
les chiffres sont là bien sûr si on va
trop vite aujourd'hui le réchauffement
climatique il est là il est extrêmement
important et c'est là où il faut être
extrêmement ambitieux et cette ambition
elle peut être portée par un grand pays
et c'est le nôtre et c'est notre
ambition c'est pour ça que plus que
jamais aujourd'hui c'est l'occasion et
pour le coup sur votre antenne ça a été
le cas de pouvoir expliquer c'est quoi
ces éléments de pression qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire et sortir de ce débat
extrêmement stérile que malheureusement
on a avec avec une ultra gauche bien sûr
qui qui pour le coup essaye de voilà
d'être en opposition systématique alors
même que les enjeux c'est des enjeux du
commun et encore une fois tous ceux qui
sont de bonne volonté seront les
bienvenus à la discussion et à notre
table pour terminer on va parler un peu
politique et vous parler justement de
l'ultra gauche qui appelle le 23
septembre à une marche contre ce qu'ils
appellent les violences policières le
racisme systémique des style de la
police là aussi on est sûr de
l'idéologie pure parce que certains
syndicats de police musée par exemple
sur l'antenne ils font ses marches mais
ne propose jamais rien c'est c'est de
l'eau trans c'est de l'outrage et pour
le coup c'est toujours très honteux
comme propos les hommes et les femmes
que j'ai toujours vu que c'est toujours
croisé qui servent nos forces de
sécurité intérieure police ou
gendarmerie ces hommes et des femmes qui
s'engagent pour protéger pour servir des
gardiens de la paix c'est c'est des gens
qui viennent servir et finalement
protéger les plus vulnérables et donc
les propos qui sont comme ça très
généralisant qui je les appelle en fait
à la haine malheureusement c'est honteux
c'est honteux et pour le coup par contre
ce qui est encore plus malheureux c'est
que ça n'étonne plus quand ça vient non
quand ça vient malheureusement d'un
certain nombre de partis politiques je
pense évidemment à la France insoumise
en particulier vous savez la police et
la police nationale en particulier c'est
une une des fonctions publiques qui est
la plus contrôlée dans notre pays ce qui
est extrêmement contrôlé
la justice tranche à chaque fois on est
dans un état de droit la loi est là pour
tout le monde et plus que jamais encore
une fois ce qui essaye de mettre là je
suis en lit dans le pays c'est ce qui
essaient d'opposer les Français entre
eux les Français face à la police ou
face aux enseignants et c'est ce
qu'appelle au désordre et plus que
jamais je crois que notre pays a besoin
de calme d'ordre peut-être un peu
d'apaisement on est en plein milieu de
l'été et profiter de ce qui nous entoure
et pour profiter de ce qui nous entoure
ça n'avance ça n'avance à rien mais bon
ça n'étonne plus on va dans un instant
faire avec mes invités le bilan des
émeutes il y a un mois jour pour jour
malheureusement la famille de Vincent
Jean Brun était était attaquée très
lâchement quel bilan rapidement vous un
mois après qu'elle regarde vous portez
sur sur ses nuits d'incidents partout en
France d'ailleurs un pas uniquement dans
les banlieues autour de Paris
effectivement l'analyse qui est faite et
qui est en train d'être faite c'est que
ça n'a pas touché que des quartiers
populaires en fait ça a touché des
villes qui pour certaines avaient des
quartiers populaires d'autres très très
marqués par la lâche très jeune de
certains de de certains émeutiers il y
avait de tout une responsabilité
parentale extrêmement forte à engagée
mais ce qui est certain c'est que c'est
grâce aux forces de sécurité intérieure
que le calme est revenu dans le pays
c'est grâce à une justice qui a été
particulièrement ferme dans ses
condamnations que finalement l'exemple
arrêté là et demain ce sera la mission
et ça a été dit d'ailleurs par le
ministre de l'éducation nationale il y a
quelques quelques jours la mission ce
sera de remettre les parents au cœur de
leur responsabilité d'accompagner aussi
c'est la priorité du président de la
République les élus locaux pour
reconstruire ce qui a été détruit parce
que dans le fond quand on s'attaque à
une mairie quand on s'attaque à une
école c'est chargé de sens et puis enfin
et je crois que c'est l'essentiel d'être
aux côtés et bien de tous ceux qui sont
les victimes collatérales de ces émeutes
parfois des hommes et des femmes des
parents qui travaillent au quotidien
tous ces tous ces Français courageux qui
ne veulent pas voir leur quartier être
pris pour cible et finalement
voilà stigmatiser par une minorité pour
ça il faut être extrêmement ferme parce
que encore une fois l'ordre protège le
plus vulnérable et c'est ce qu'il faut
rappeler pour terminer je me permets une
petite question sur une aussi des
informations du jour le décès de
Geneviève de Fontenay vous-même est-ce
que ça fait partie des des personnages
qu'on marqués peut-être je sais pas
petite fille votre parcours ou on
connaît tous les châteaux exactement les
chapeaux de Madame de Fontenay je pense
évidemment dans un moment comme ça à sa
famille parce que ça reste ça reste un
deuil et dans le fond c'est c'est une
femme c'est un nom qui restera dans
notre patrimoine dans notre patrimoine
culturel et historique et ça a été ça a
été cette dame dont on reconnaît la
silhouette donc je pense que cette
silhouette restera dans l'esprit des
Français merci